[Musique]
nouveau record de cas en 24 heures plus
de 52000 comme indiqué ici 52000 cas par
jour en fait le double très
vraisemblement plus de cent mille cas
tous les jours ça veut dire dans trois
semaines il ya à peu près on va dire 250
personnes qui vont mourir en réanimation
cette deuxième vague va être drôlement
plus forte que la première vague
c'était le retentissement 10 de morts
que le retentissement sur les systèmes
de santé et et va être là dans
l'immédiat dans les trois semaines qui
viennent ça paraît quasi 20% des
personnes dépistées qui sont positives
donc on sait une situation wiki hors de
contrôle on peut le dire je pense que
beaucoup de gens beaucoup de nos
concitoyens n'ont pas encore pris
conscience de ce qui nous attend il ya
eu quatre jours de froid entre le 24 et
27 septembre avec par endroits des
chutes maximale de température de 25
degrés et une semaine plus tard le
nombre de cas a augmenté façon brutale à
très très brutale et ça c'est ce dont on
avait discuté auparavant c'est que c'est
un virus qui comme beaucoup rêver sur
respiratoire est hivernale m le froid
dans ce contexte les médecins libéraux
de la région auvergne rhône-alpes
appelle un durcissement des mesures déjà
en cours
ils demandent notamment l'élargissement
immédiat des horaires du couvre-feu à
partir de 19h en semaine
aujourd'hui on est tous le nez dans une
situation terrible 100 kg et de réponse
très forte de l'exécutif
et bah oui monsieur oui monsieur il ne
reste plus que le confinement
le problème dure au confinement total
c'est qu'on va faire perdre des chances
aux patients qui viennent pour d'autres
pathologies qui nécessitent une
hospitalisation ou un service de
réanimation
il ya trop de malades qui arrivent et
donc il ya des malades qu'on peut plus
prendre à l'hôpital les malades qu'on
peut plus prendre à l'hôpital c'est les
passions des ehpad chez les personnes
les plus âgées les plus fragiles et ben
les ehpad sont sacrifiés est-ce qu'il va
falloir aller vers 1 re confinement non
je vais vous faire une confidence
pauline de mahler ou je ne suis plus
ministre de la santé depuis dix ans
alors pousser ça secoue
ensuite on n'exclut rien mais vous avez
compris qu'on souhaite éviter un recond
finement générale et qu'en tout cas on
veut trouver un bon équilibre entre la
protection de la santé des français
et puis la poursuite de l'activité
économique éducatif culturel est ce que
véritablement la solution sera un
confinement massive comme celui qu'on a
vécu au mois de mars seront à 2 2 mais
je n'ai pas les éléments aujourd'hui
pour vous répondre à pauline de mahler
j'ai ce sentiment que nous allons
confinement c'est certes peut-être un
avertissement mais c'est aussi je crois
un cri d'alarmé credal est responsable
je pense qu'il commence déjà à préparer
les esprits en confinement puisque
jusqu'à maintenant ils prônent ils ne
prononcez pas lé nom et depuis environ
une semaine si j'ai bien analysé le
discours il re prononce le nom de
confinement en disant que c'est
envisageable
cette cyberattaque qui par sa symbolique
inquiète nos autorités de nombreux sites
internet français ont été hackés hier
laissant apparaître des messages haineux
à destination notamment des manuels
macron le chef de l'état qui a
d'ailleurs twitté en français en anglais
et en arabe
rien ne nous fera reculer jamais
monsieur erdogan est insultant
islamistes qui agit comme une grenade
dégoupillée qui souhaite reconquérir
autour de l'île empire ottoman et qui
n'a de cesse d'organiser des agressions
à l'égard de l'union européenne hier le
président r doan récidive
ces derniers jours l'individu à la tête
de la france a été surpris il est obsédé
par hyères doan jour et nuit
regardez-vous d'abord comme j'ai dit
hier c'est un cas et il a donc vraiment
besoin de subir des examens de
l'attitude du président erdogan est de
la turquie qui est un pays islamique et
qui pourrait à certains égards devenir
islamiste est inquiétante et il faudrait
pas que les musulmans modérés s'agrègent
et que du combat contre l'islamisme
on en vienne à un combat contre l'islam